Hello everybody!
And welcome to We Are Virgin!
A millionaire today!
Oh wait, wrong show, sorry.
You could be a millionaire if you win enough money!
It's time to family feud!
Wait, it's another wrong show, sorry.
There is no family in feuding.
What's the most money someone has won in Wheel of Fortune before?
Should be a million, right?
We'll find out today!
Yes, we have.
Actually, we'll introduce everybody starting from the pink one.
Hello everybody!
I am Muchawa and today I'm very cute.
I'm excited to be here.
And if you like Minto, please donate generously.
Because she will be giving the money to us as a prize.
Yippee!
This is the character you chose?
Listen!
I have to be cute.
I don't know how to be cute.
God damn it, I'm doing my best.
I'm really freaking dry in here, girl.
I feel like I should change some of the... I'm gonna change the names actually.
But if we have to do voices, what on earth would the voice be for a crow?
Oh no, it's just me.
Ah!
Oh, just...
I'm like AHHHHH!
AHHHHH!
Why does it fit so fast?
Hello, it is iCrowKey.
I'm here to win some big money right now.
We're not late because of me, by the way.
We were...
Oh yeah, totally not.
It wasn't because of me!
I swear!
Girl, I just thought it'd be funny!
She had to commit to the bit, everybody.
And last but not least...
Hello, my name is Lamont.
No, it's Limes.
I'm here today...
Lamont?
My mascot's name is Lamont!
No, I am using Lamont today because I don't have a chibi version of my model.
And my normal model was really fat and was causing problems.
He's erotically chubby!
Stop it!
Fat isn't layer fat!
Layer fat!
Yeah.
Damn.
Should I show what happened?
Are you guys okay with that?
Yeah, show what happened, why we're...
Before you do, Koki, can you open your mouth?
Okay, yeah, don't worry, I'm dying a little bit.
We'll catch up soon, don't worry!
Oh, it's a little... you guys, today...
Really scuffed!
Wait, can I reshare?
Maybe it's because I'm 1440p right now, maybe that...
Oh, wait, hold on, I'm trying to save the pictures.
Let me change, I'm on 1440p, I'm too high quality.
Oh, you're back, you're back!
Okay, open your mouth, open your mouth.
Oh my god.
I think that'll work, hopefully it works.
Like this.
Hopefully, you don't say stop for anything.
Wait, should I reshare so I'm not 1440p?
No!
Would that be easier?
It's okay!
Because I'm talking right now, but I'm not moving.
Every now and again, it just looks like you're really good at sitting still at the same time.
It's really impressive.
No, I think it's Discord.
Or rather, I think it's the window share.
Okay.
I think I have to...
Do you want to disable it?
Oh, is it because you're not focusing the window share?
And it's like...
Yeah, I think that's it.
So I think how it is right now should be keeping good.
Okay, that's good.
I thought it was because I was too HD croaky.
My computer is chugging.
You guys, so I started a collab room in a VTube studio for everybody to join.
And Matara first comes in like this.
When I'm open, when I'm sleeping.
And then we have...
What is...
This looks like Ben drowned Lime.
Oh.
I got sunburned.
Yeah, you got a nice little tan there.
Yeah, sunburned.
I think I burnt the eyes off too.
But then also Matara had then no eyes.
We were just all over the place.
But then the last is my favorite.
This one's my favorite.
Yeah, it's Doki's.
With the goatee.
Goatee.
Lime said that it looks like the lady from Mulan.
The matchmaker lady.
The matchmaker.
Don't worry, I'll find a girl for you guys.
Don't worry.
So yeah, now that's why we're all as we are now.
Yeah, that's why we brought our alternate selves.
Yeah.
We have too many layers.
Too many clothes on.
We gotta take our clothes off.
That's why we're naked now.
Wait.
I'm wearing clothes.
I'm wearing clothes now.
You were.
I'm not wearing clothes.
Lime and I are...
You are definitely not wearing clothes, Lime.
Look, you're like flaunting it out.
Lime, extend.
Pause.
I'm not wearing clothes and I'm like spreading.
You're like...
You're manspreading.
Show yourself.
You're like literally manspreading right now, Lime.
Look at those legs.
Oh my god.
We're all very cute.
We're on live television too.
On live television.
We're gonna have to give censor back.
Oh my god.
This is gonna be the last episode of Wheel of Fortune.
Ever.
Are we all showing our feetsies?
Are we?
Maybe.
I see mint feetsies.
Yeah, okay.
Go ahead and show yours, Mataro.
Okay, Kroky, you're next.
No, Kroky, you're next.
Wait, show what?
Feet.
Your feet.
My feet?
Oh, wait.
I have to...
Wait, I have to show...
Hold on.
I can move you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Show it.
Whoa.
That's right, boy.
We're on this channel only.
Whoa.
Wow.
All right, Mataro.
Your turn.
All right.
These are my feetsies.
Whoa.
How do you stand up?
You only have two toes.
I have two toesies.
I'm a man.
I'm an alien, girl.
Don't make fun of me.
What?
I think Doki's trying to eat your feet.
She's nibbling on you.
This has turned into an episode of Jerry Springer.
This is not that kind of television.
I'm not that kind of orc.
Well, guys, welcome to Wheel of Fortune.
Let's start our first game.
Oh, let me explain for those who don't know how to play.
Anyone at home as well.
So, essentially, there will be given a category.
The category could be phrase.
It could be food.
It could be the... your mom.
My mom?
Don't put my mom as a category.
She was last night.
She gets to pass.
It's her birth...
Okay, it's not her birthday, but it's her stream birthday.
It is my birthday.
It's...
So careful.
I was...
I'm not going to be around your mom at Thanksgiving.
I'm not in any time zone right now.
Oh, you're right.
Now we're past it.
Yes, past your birthday.
But yeah, so you'll be given...
Don't have to birth these hoopa.
Sabotaging my stream?
So yeah, you'll be given a phrase, or a word, or whatever.
And you spin your wheel.
And you land on a certain money amount, monetary amount.
And you guess a letter.
However many of that letter is in the word or phrase, you'll get that much money.
And you'll have to be able to get money to buy vowels.
And then once you know, you can solve it!
And after that, when you solve it, I'm gonna have to watch the tutorial because I don't know.
I don't know where to go from there.
Also...
Oh shit, wait, that's a real game?
Do we win real money?
I thought you made this in Photoshop.
I didn't realize this was the game.
Yeah, this is a real game!
Yeah!
I thought you made it in Photoshop.
No!
She was just gonna be dragging letters onto the board in Clip Studio Paint or some shit?
She's gonna drag letters to the wall and get a fucking Google wheel.
No!
I went fancy!
Alright, let's start our first round then.
Let's get to it.
Okay.
How do I do this?
Oh, load a puzzle.
Okay, hold on.
You got this.
I got this.
Okay, one.
You're doing amazing.
Dun-dun-dun!
This is... the category is a stream quote.
So a quote from a stream.
It's probably a popular quote.
Probably?
Ah.
Said by maybe a Vtuber somewhere.
Mm-hmm.
So we're gonna start with Matawa.
We have your wheel.
I might need help.
So I have to spin the wheel?
Yes.
Okay.
Spin that wheel.
Yeah!
Spin that wheel!
Spin, spin, spin, spin.
Oh, okay, goodbye.
That was really exciting.
Thanks, guys.
I guess so.
I had my letter and stuff.
Spin that wheel.
I had my letter.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
My turn.
Time for Croaky to...
Yay!
Spin that wheel!
I swear to...
Whoa!
2,500.
Holy cow.
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking rich.
Wait, isn't that the second most expensive you can get?
I don't know.
So what's your letter?
A.
You have to buy the...
I would like to buy a letter.
You have no money.
Wait, did I not get 2,500?
No, you only get that amount.
If you get the letter.
You have to get the letter, guys.
I'm the only one who has no fucking clue what they're doing.
Can I have an IOU?
I know.
In honor of Croaky, I choose C.
All right.
For Croaky, I choose C.
C!
You copycat.
I was going to do M for Matawa.
Oh.
No C?
No C.
No!
So sorry for you.
Well, I'm...
Do I still get money?
Hello.
Oh.
You ready to spin the wheel?
I am ready to spin the wheel.
Next time.
Stop eating me!
What?
What do you think?
I'm on the ground.
What the fuck?
What are these?
At least it's good that you roll it now.
Yeah.
You get it now instead of...
There's no way you're going to get it again.
What are these spins?
What do you mean?
I got a good spin.
It just wasn't C.
You're just stupid.
All right.
Spin my wheel.
Matawa.
I can go with this.
Spin my wheel.
Marinate me.
There you go.
Oh.
Give me some good.
$700.
All right.
I choose M for Matawa.
Wow.
M.
Let's see.
Is there any M's on the board?
No.
No M's.
I got so many M's.
Oh, I got one.
I know.
I bet my next letter is going to work.
Okay.
Let's see.
You're going to get bankrupt.
If you even have a turn.
There's no way.
$600?
Yeah.
Okay.
$600.
I choose L.
L.
Is there an L on the board?
No.
What?
How?
What is this?
I don't think this place has any letters.
What did you put in there?
There's no L.
It could be anything.
Can we get some L's in chat?
There's already plenty of L's in there.
I mean, we're all technically L-ing right now.
Well, it's a good thing Lime didn't go L for Limes.
Yeah.
I don't want to do L letters.
No.
Okay.
I had a turn.
I had two turns.
All right.
It's a good thing I have my glasses.
That's great.
All right.
Ready, Lime?
I'm going to keep my eyes.
He's eating my eyes.
That's right.
You're a bug.
Wow.
Number?
500.
I pick T.
T.
Is there a T on the board?
Two T's!
And there wasn't an M?
Sorry.
Or an L?
Or a C?
I think you get to go again, Lime.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
How much does a L cost?
How much does a vowel cost?
250, I think.
Oh.
Wait.
250.
Like, not 2,500.
Just 250.
250.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah.
Pick O.
Do we spin again?
Or do I just pick another one?
Um.
Uh.
She surely knows.
Min, you're the host.
Oh, spin again.
Okay.
Yeah.
You spin again.
Okay.
Spin.
Is that real?
Spin for Lime.
800.
800?
Wow.
Okay.
I pick H.
H.
Is there an H on the board?
You're so smart.
Two.
Wow.
That kind of makes things a little more clear, I'd say.
Okay.
Oh, and your money.
Thank you for my money.
You're welcome.
Um.
Do you spin again?
Yes.
Oh, do you want to do a vowel?
I think it's either spin or vowel.
We're trying to distract her.
I would like a vowel.
Okay.
I will pick E, please.
E.
How do I distract the money?
Yes.
E.
Oh, she did it.
Ta-da!
You only pay once?
This is her one turn.
Wow.
I'm doing stuff.
Yeah.
Something, something, be something, something.
You can read?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I can.
Something, something.
Don't look at chat, just in case they get it, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah.
Do I spin again?
I spin again.
Yeah, you're killing it.
You're on a roll.
Wait.
Does you get that money?
I think you get the money, too.
You get the money.
Guys, I don't think Matara and I are ever going to have a turn anymore.
No.
Trophy, you remember her in Lockdown Protocol.
She's a gamer.
This is it.
We're done.
This is not fair.
Are you ready?
You're smarter than the average YouTuber.
This is not fair.
Did you know she had a real job?
Oh, my God.
It went up.
$850.
Oh, my God.
It went up.
Okay.
Let me think about it for a second.
I hope I spelled these right.
No.
Stop thinking.
It's not fair to the non-thinkers.
Go with your guts.
Stop thinking.
You already have $3,150.
Don't think.
Just do.
Just pick.
N.
Is there an N on the board?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Lime is rich, Rich.
Lime is going to get it.
I don't think we can catch up anymore.
I think we have to get it.
I think she just wins.
You don't get money for vowels.
Oh.
Oh, this is rigged!
Sorry.
Well, we're doing money for vowels in this version.
Okay, guys?
I think it's because they're both green.
That's what's going on, Croaky.
I can't believe it.
This is bootleg Wheel of Fortune.
This is not endorsed by Wheel of Fortune.
I can't believe it.
Wheel.
Here, let's spin.
I'd like to buy a vowel, though.
Just kidding.
We're going to buy a vowel.
Oh, please.
Oh!
Yeah.
Subtract.
No!
What?
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Wait, does this mean it's my turn?
It's your turn, Matawa.
Unless you go bankrupt.
Or lose a turn.
I don't have any money.
It's okay.
You don't need to have a vowel.
You can buy it later.
Okay.
Five hundred dollars.
What would you like to guess?
Okay.
I have to...
This is tough.
Yeah.
I need to get the letter right.
But I don't know what the letter is.
Guess anything.
It could be any letter.
Go with your heart.
Yeah.
I need a letter.
Stop thinking.
All right.
May I please have an S?
S.
Like serpentine.
Is there any S's on the board?
Is it?
No.
Oh, no.
This is the line we'll sweep right here.
Kroki, you still have a chance.
Back to you, Kroki.
You have a chance.
Wait.
I mean Kroki.
Who's Doki?
Yeah.
Kroki.
$500 for you, Kroki.
Oh, no.
And I think you can solve it anytime.
Yeah, but like what the fuck is that?
Something, something, V, something, something.
Think of famous like Vtuber quotes set on stream.
What?
You think I remember that?
I just remember my own quotes.
I swear.
She's a bear.
She's a bird.
She's a bird brain, you guys.
Yeah.
Um.
R.
Two.
I would like to buy a power.
What would you like to buy?
That's a good question.
Okay.
There's only three.
Oh.
You guys.
A.
One.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
Uh.
Yup.
Um.
Go.
Come on, Kroki.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Spin the wheel.
Oh, spin the wheel.
Wait, wait.
I think I have a letter for this.
Okay.
I think I have a letter.
Oh, 900.
Okay.
Double.
W.
W?
Ooh.
Yeah.
Because I was like, that has to be Y.
Ah.
What the fuck is the third word?
I think, I think you can pretty much solve it, Kroki, if you just guess it genuinely.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Buy.
Wait.
Can I buy a vowel?
Can I solve it after?
Why don't you just solve it now?
I don't know what the fuck is the third word.
Okay.
Buy a vowel.
Wait, wait.
Buy can solve it after, right?
I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, I would like to buy I.
I.
Bing.
Oh.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Okay.
You got this, Kroki.
So, this is water in the blank.
Okay.
Oh, that's fire.
Yeah.
Put the water in the fire.
What's, what the fuck is...
I don't know.
It's either why or who, but there's no more O.
Oh.
Stop helping her.
What kind of conversation is this?
Oh, sorry.
I mean, she was gonna win anyway.
I helped a little too.
What's the answer?
Water in the fire.
Why?
I don't remember which one we don't have.
Yay.
I don't know.
I don't know how much money you get.
Um.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Hold on.
Let me watch the tutorial.
That's a quote?
Wait, whose quote is that?
That's from Korone.
I like how...
You still have less money than I.
I know.
You really do.
Yeah.
But I have less money than both of you.
Yay.
Hold on.
Let me watch the tutorial real quick and see what happens at the end of the game.
You're watching the tutorial.
Okay.
And transfer Jo's round score to Jo's total.
Oh, okay.
I have the total.
Okay.
Clear the board.
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh!
Wait!
What happened to the total money?
You stole my money!
What?
Wait.
What happened to it?
The plot twist.
Just like...
You stole her money.
Wait.
This is live television.
Where'd the money go?
This is reality TV.
Why?
She's just trying not to give you your payout.
Oh.
Only the winner gets the payout?
Only the winner keeps their money.
This is some bullshit.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see.
Wait.
That's mean.
American game Jo's.
Wait.
Huh?
I got the money.
Wait.
So I don't lose that money, right?
It's in the totals.
Well, only the winner gets paid.
Oh, okay.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Only the winner gets paid.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, Lon.
Wait.
I just realized none of us playing are American.
Yeah.
I know.
Oh, yeah.
It's true.
I know.
I don't even know how to play this game.
I...
Okay.
Well, I think we'll start with Lime next because we ended with Grokey.
So, next round.
Yeah.
Let's go to a...
Go, go.
Power Lime.
Wait.
How do I go to the next round?
Oh, here we go.
You're doing a great job hosting.
Yeah.
You're doing great.
Thanks.
It's a little rigged, but you're doing great.
How is it rigged?
I literally won.
I speak for the people.
We won.
I appreciate it.
Wait.
Grokey, open your mouth.
She speaks for the people.
All right.
This round is a game title.
All right, guys.
That's slightly more in my ballpark.
Let's go.
Yeah.
I made all these prompts, by the way, guys.
So...
Yeah.
But it's not Metal Gear Solid.
I can tell.
That would be the shortest Metal Gear Solid I've ever seen.
Well Lime, are you ready to spin your wheel?
Yes, I am.
What's the question mark?
Five hundred dollars.
I pick tea.
Tea!
Is there a tea on the board?
He's so brilliant.
No tea.
No tea!
No tea, so it's not the...
No, it's not the something.
Oh my god, I'm up next.
Alright, Metawa.
Spin.
Spin that wheel.
No!
No, you landed on a mystery.
Wait, what does that do?
I like it on the mystery.
You gotta get that letter.
Don't fail.
Maybe it's H.
No, it's M for me.
M for Metawa, please.
M for Metawa?
Is it M for Metawa?
Yeah!
Yay!
One M!
Oh my god, it actually worked.
One small M for Metawa.
One giant leap for my bank account.
Can I please buy the vowel?
Eh.
What?
She wants to buy a vowel.
What is it?
Eh?
It's after A.
And before E.
Wait.
A, E?
Yeah, it's E.
It's E.
No, no, no.
It's E, E, E.
E, E.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
I was being dumb.
My coffee's getting weird.
I think, okay, I'm gonna not do the, the, the, you get the vowel money though because that's apparently not how you play.
Oh, oh, oh.
Now that you gotta give me money, you don't wanna entice me.
Yeah.
It would be $10,000.
It's $10,000.
So E?
Yeah.
E?
E.
Okay.
Is there a E on the board?
Give me an E.
There it is.
There is, there is.
What the fuck is this game?
Is it a game that you recently played?
I'm gonna look at your channel right now.
No, I haven't recently played.
No, don't look down.
Look down.
I'm gonna look at your bottom.
Oh.
So, I think you spin the wheel again, I think, or unless you want to buy another vowel.
I spin wheel.
Spin wheel.
Spin the wheel.
$550.
May I get a...
N.
An N.
Is there an N on the board?
Is there an N?
No N.
I thought I... I thought I had it.
You almost had it.
You really did.
I thought I had it because it's Halloween and I thought you did that.
What was it?
What was the game you were thinking of?
I thought it was Ink Machine.
But it would have been Bendy and the Ink Machine, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, no.
That's way more wholesome than how I was thinking.
Alright, Croaky, we spin the wheel for you.
Spin that wheel.
Spin the wheel.
$500.
I have no idea what the fuck this game is.
What is it?
Give me...
Give me an...
Oh, my God.
Give me a...
L.
Is there an L on the board?
She's stealing your letter line.
Well, it's a good thing.
Thank you.
Thank God.
Croaky taking another L.
One day the L will work.
One day.
Lime, are you ready?
Yes.
Lime, we gotta work together so Matari doesn't get $10,000.
Wait, but you did work.
We did work together for you not to get money like this.
$650.
Oh, you almost got the mystery.
Yeah.
S, please.
S.
S on the board.
The consensus is...
Oh, yes.
Sorry.
What is it?
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait.
Can I guess?
Can I guess already?
Yes, you can.
Is it orc massage?
You are such...
Is that orc massage?
A little freak.
Oh, my God.
Lime, have you played that game yet?
No, but my chat won't shut the fuck up about it.
They're like, stream your orc massage.
You didn't play orc massage?
It will be funny.
Oh, goodbye Matara's $10,000.
Oh, goodbye.
Nice job, Lime.
Nice job.
We worked together.
Good job, Lime.
You put the L so she didn't pick it and then she got the winnings.
Exactly.
That's the only reason why I picked the L.
Lime, I'm impressed you knew from social media.
Wait, Mint, have you played orc massage, Mint?
You know, actually, I haven't.
Wait, you haven't?
Wait, am I the only one that's played orc massage?
When?
Why?
I mean, it was either massage or missive and I couldn't think of any games with the word missive in it, so...
No, okay.
So, like, I wanted to see what orc massage is all about because everybody kept talking about it.
So, I bought it on an alt steam account, so...
Oh, my God.
But the thing was...
Coward.
No, no, no.
People found out because, like, I had my Discord status on, so it said, Turkey is playing.
Still got outed.
How was it, you know, thinking, like, game-wise, game-wise?
It's, it's, it's, it's, I got to, like, the bird girl and then I stopped.
There's a bird girl?
There's four, there's three...
Oh, sorry, guys.
Oh, there's three plus different girls and I got to, like, the bird girl and then it was, it was pretty...
It gets intense, the massage part, of course.
I'm talking about the massage part.
The massage part.
Wait, do you massage orcs?
Are the orcs the one massaging?
No, the orc is the massager and you get, like, employed by goblins to massage monster girls.
Oh.
Sounds like a book I've read before.
Right, Mataji?
No, no, no, no.
Please, Mataji.
Well, it's not a minotaur milking farm, Mataji, no.
Only podcast listeners will know.
No.
I kind of wish I hadn't guessed now because, like, my chat will not leave me alone now.
It's like, wow, Shaymin, how come you're so familiar with orc massaging?
Limes, you have outed yourself as a little pervert.
You have.
Yeah.
That's, okay.
We're going to take...
Gotta own it.
A quick commercial break.
Okay.
And everybody don't leave.
We're going to go to commercial break and we'll be back after these messages.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye.
Everything is great at your goodness.
Let's go to the next round.
I think you guys should run more commercials on this channel.
Are you guys getting monetized enough?
I have more commercials.
It's an ad break right now.
Oh my god, I should.
Yeah, you should have done like pre-roll ads.
We had a commercial real quick and then ran a pre-roll.
Alrighty.
Lime, since you won last, we'll start with Matawa this time.
Okay, I spin the wheel and I choose M.
Oh, so fast.
You might just lose a turn.
I really wish you had.
I forgot to say the category is advice.
M.
Is there an M on the board?
Like platitudes?
A single M.
Is it advice from a stream or like your own personal advice?
It's like if someone were to come up to you on the street and be like, hey, here's some advice.
Okay.
So like generic or sort of like well-known advice.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Matawa, what do you want to do?
Spin again or buy a vowel?
Spin.
No.
You buy a vowel.
No, you buy a vowel.
You should have bought a vowel.
Lime.
You should have done this.
You should have bought a vowel.
I'm really sorry to you.
Well, I guess it's Croaky's turn.
Yay.
Spin that wheel.
Your money.
Yeah.
L.
Why did you still have to pick this one?
It'll work eventually.
Is there an L on the board?
What?
Yeah.
A single L for you.
Matawa, don't cry.
This is literally showbiz, baby.
Okay.
Yeah.
Welcome to show business.
Spin that wheel.
I'm the one that got the L this turn.
It's true.
It's okay.
You can always make a comeback.
$500.
Okay.
$500?
I don't know.
Give me a...
Give me a Y.
Y.
Is there a Y?
That's what Shakespeare once said.
Do you want a Y?
Is there a Y on the board?
No.
There is.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Spin that wheel.
Oh, you don't want to buy a vowel?
You selfish?
I want Lime to buy it.
I want Lime to buy a vowel.
How am I supposed to buy a vowel?
You are so selfish.
I don't have money.
You were telling me, Matawa, buy a vowel.
But you keep only getting $500.
So just keep going.
All right.
Okay.
S.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Got it.
Literally.
One by one.
Just taken it down.
All right.
What do you want to do now?
Oh, okay.
Now, this is being a little difficult.
Bowel, vowel, vowel.
Vowel, vowel, vowel, vowel.
Bowel, vowel, vowel, vowel, vowel.
What is the cheapest vowel?
They are all cost the same.
There is no vowel hierarchy.
They are all...
I don't care.
They should be.
The game is worth the money.
Phohus and you.
All right.
Okay.
Good job.
You should be the lowest tier in the Vow hierarchy.
Yes, it is.
You rarely see words with you in it.
I think...
The word you.
Okay, if I buy a Vow and I pick you, is it going to get anything?
I don't know.
I can't spoil for you.
It's just going to prove a point if I choose you.
I choose you, Pikachu.
No, I didn't.
I didn't choose it.
Oh, I think she said, I choose you.
Is there a you on the board?
No!
Loki, you were proven wrong.
Yeah, I knew it.
Yeah, you were proven wrong.
I knew it.
What the fuck is S...
Like, S you what?
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, we're going to spin, I think.
Wait, I know like... I know like half this word... I know half this sentence.
Do you?
I think so.
Say it.
Yeah, the salt.
Lime wants to hear it.
Okay, wait, wait, spin the wheel.
Just spin that wheel.
Spin that wheel!
Wait, can you hop salt by guessing?
By guessing words?
I don't think so.
No.
You have to guess the whole thing.
No, I was going to say.
Yeah.
Okay.
You would just buy the letters for it.
Oh, wait, I should have just bought the... bought a vowel because I sort of know.
You got a $900 spin!
Okay.
I don't know the top part.
Well, just guess anything.
Guess what you know.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Oh, why?
Oh, my God.
I don't know the top part.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, my God.
You are kidding.
I got it.
Oh, my God.
Okay guys, nice.
Ahhhhhh...
Alright, lime in your big brain.
It's up to you.
There's no pressure then.
No pressure.
Oh, 900.
Nice!
You should buy a vowel.
I can't buy a vowel until I actually have the money.
You're like the devil on the shoulder, so the devil just gives really shitty advice.
That's why you listen to me, because it's fun advice.
It might be shitty, but it's fun.
You should get that tramp stamp.
I'm hoping that I'm right on the last word.
An N!
Is there an N on the board?
That's what I was thinking, too.
Oh my god, I thought it would be like, soon.
This is targeted.
Yeah, this is insane.
You weren't allowed to get this weird.
Lime, you gotta touch more grass, Lime.
It's so poetic that Lime got this.
I'll have everybody know, at Anime Expo, Lime kept wearing big sun hats.
Because she didn't want to avoid the sun.
It's healthy.
It was targeted.
I've gotten this advice, too.
Damn, girl.
You need sun.
Awesome.
Well, right now, we have Lime in the lead with $4,000.
Croaky in second with $1,900.
And Matawa doing her best.
Let's go to the next puzzle.
Let's go.
Number five.
I love being top three.
This one is an event.
An event?
An event.
Alright.
Well, Lime won, so we'll start with you, Matawa.
Okay.
To the shock of nobody, I will get money.
You will get money.
Matara, please.
Matara.
We need Matara.
Please.
You gotta pick something real calm.
I bet on you, Matara.
You went from third place to second place.
Don't bet on me.
I'm bad.
I don't know.
Okay.
I pick...
M for Matara.
Are you sure?
Okay.
I don't think there's an M, Matara.
Is there an M?
She's here trying to give you an M.
What if you flip the M upside down?
Instead of Mumbo, it's Wumbo.
Are we gonna ditch M for Matara, your old name?
Alright.
Is there an M?
Nah, nah.
I, I, I, I, uh...
What is it?
What is the word?
I commit to Matara.
She commits to the bet.
Okay.
No.
Yippee.
Spin that wheel.
Alright.
I'm backed up in my heart.
Oh.
Okay.
I would like to pick W.
W.
Oh my god.
There's my M.
Who could have guessed?
Wait, wait, wait.
You know what, doki, you should buy a B.
You should buy a B and get the tramp stamp.
I didn't learn how to spell real quick.
What?
Do a doki, buy the B.
Buy the B.
WrestleTuber.
Ah!
Yay!
Why is everyone who gets their own thing so mad?
Was that the play though?
Because I don't think either of us were to get it.
So you could have farmed more money.
Yeah, you could have farmed more money.
I could have, but I also had to count to see if it fit.
I'm so excited.
I'm counting to see if it actually fit.
I guess I could have farmed mine for more money too.
The game is telling me a minimum of a thousand dollars has to be transferred.
There we go.
Okay, give me a thousand.
Okay, you actually got a thousand.
It's not rigged, it's just showbiz, baby.
I'm still in third!
Yay!
Alright, let's go to our next...
Wait, hold on, let me see what the next one is.
Ah, okay, okay.
Our next puzzle...
Uh, wait.
It's a place!
A place.
Oh wait, before we do this puzzle...
A real place?
Sorry, I have another ad.
Oh, yay, yay, yay!
Sorry, I gotta go through the ads.
Sorry everybody, we'll be back after this quick commercial break.
You can think of what this could be after this quick commercial break.
We'll be right back.
Yes, your house is haunted.
It's haunted by me!
Don't be fooled, those are not boobs on my chest.
That's my butt bleeding through the back.
Because I'm a ghost.
You can see it's right through me.
Yes, I'm haunting this place.
And I'll keep haunting it until a more powerful, a stronger, a cooler ghost comes and takes my heart.
Which will never happen.
What is that?
This energy.
This great energy.
I feel...
That great energy, whatever could it be?
Why, it's the Mint Phantom Happy Coat.
Of course.
You can get your own official Mint Phantom Happy Coat for yours to keep.
It's so soft.
It's so powerful.
It will keep all other spirits at bay.
Get your own Mint Phantom Happy Coat today.
And they're on sale.
Pre-order right now.
So head to the YeahLights website and get yours today.
And we're back, ladies and gentlemen.
Yes.
I'm suddenly craving a coat.
A coat?
That's mysterious.
I know.
You feel very powerful wearing mine.
And happy.
Oh my god.
No skip of the ads.
You have ad blocker on, right guys?
Yes.
Yeah.
Why?
Okie dokie.
He was number one.
Croaky won last round.
So we're going to start this one of the place with lime.
Yay.
Alright.
So you said this was places.
Is it real places or can it be pretend places?
Pretend.
Places.
Oh, it's pretend places then it is.
Not a real place.
Well, it's a real place, though.
Ok.
But it's also.
Is it in Metal Gear Solid?
No.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Actually, maybe.
Who knows.
It's Metal Gear Solid, guys.
This is not Metal Gear Solid.
We have 20 questions.
This is Wheel of Fortune.
$500 live.
I pick...
S.
Is there...
an S on the board?
No, I put the L.
No, S.
That was so cute.
That was cute.
Alright, spin the wheel.
Spin the wheel.
I don't know why it's in my head.
Yeah, wheel.
Yeah.
Pick M.
How did you know?
How did you know I was going to pick M?
I could read your mind.
What am I thinking about now?
M.
Wait, I'm going to think about something else.
What am I thinking about now?
Matara.
For Matara.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm going to think about something completely different, okay?
Try to figure it out.
Okay, wait.
3, 2, 1.
M.
For Matara.
Oh my god, she knows me.
She knows me so well.
I told you.
Psycho Doki.
Psycho Mantis.
Ning.
May I please have an M?
Okay.
Why are you laughing?
There was no M.
No.
Alright, Krokin.
Eventually Matara, I bet.
Spin that wheel.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, that was close.
Yeah.
I had zero dollars, so.
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, what do you want?
Alright, I will pick L.
L.
Yeah.
Oh gosh, who said that?
Apparently, I just have to take the opportunity to pick L whenever I can.
Yeah, in other words, get sniped.
That's your fault for not picking L.
Yeah, I guess so.
I am Doki's conscience.
Would it have benefited you to pick L?
No.
No!
I shouldn't have listened to that demon on my shoulder.
This could be anyone's game, Matara.
Let's spin the wheel.
Oh, sorry, live.
She's winning.
She doesn't deserve this turn.
Um, could I please have T?
T!
I remember last time the T worked for you.
It's T time!
Just one.
But she got a letter!
One letter.
I'm on the board, let's go!
Do you want to spin or do you want to buy a vowel?
I spin.
Spin.
Spin, spin, spin, spin, spin, spin.
Oh, no!
Oh, yes!
I'm going to take everything.
I'm so sorry.
Even the 4,000.
Wait, does it not take her 4,000?
No, it only takes her because she banked it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stop trying to lose me more money, Matara.
Whoa!
Just because I'm not picking M over and over again.
Wow!
Yeah, all right.
Do you like great ads to lose your money?
Quickly, put it in a Super Chat and give it to Mint.
This show is brought to you by sponsors like you.
Matara, you're at $700.
Okay.
Doki, what am I thinking?
What am I thinking, Doki?
You're thinking T for Tara.
We already have T.
Doki, what are we thinking?
R for Ra.
Okay.
I am thinking N.
A single N!
Good job!
All right, you want to spin or do you want to buy a vowel?
Spin, spin, spin.
Spin, spin, spin!
All right, Doki, what am I thinking?
You're thinking O.
It better be worth $850.
That's a vowel.
Sorry, I forgot my vowels.
I'm not going to buy.
Okay, okay, okay.
I want to buy an H for Matara.
Wait, buy?
Matara?
No, not buy, sorry.
I want to get an H for Matara.
An H?
Is there an H on the board?
Bing!
There it is!
Oh my god.
What is that face?
Is this her comeback?
I should have said for hag.
Why did I say for Hatara?
All right, do you want to spin or do you want to buy a vowel?
You should buy a vowel.
Okay, hold on.
I have to think.
It's hard.
Bing, bong, bing, bong.
Bing, bong, bong.
Can I spin the wheel?
Yes, you can.
Or you may.
This is...
I'm shy.
This is hard.
Oh, okay.
I hate this game!
I'm never going back to the spinning wheel!
All right, spin that wheel!
Spin that wheel!
Okay.
Well, I had zero dollars, so that's all right, I guess.
All right, Lime!
Lime, we're spinning the wheel for you.
This is rigged for Lime.
Give me more clues, but all right.
That's right.
All right, 700 dollars.
Let me think.
Don't think, just do.
Don't think.
R,
please.
R!
That's the letter my conscience was telling me to pick.
You should have picked it.
I told you!
You should have listened to me!
I never failed you!
You should have picked it!
I told you!
I was going to pick that, too!
A lot, a lot of R's.
Might as well be pirate day.
R!
What would you like to do?
Would you like a buy a vowel, Lime, or would you like to spit?
Buy a vowel.
That's not...
Your name is not Lime!
Buy a vowel and get a trap now.
You have so much money already, Lime!
What's the minus fifty dollars to you?
Could I pick... actually, I want a wheel, please.
A wheel!
I would like to wheel, please.
Five hundred dollars.
Okay, I pick F.
F!
A single F?
Okay.
Oh, are you farming?
Wait, I think I know.
I think I know the first one.
Oh, no.
Well, of course you would know, Lime.
What are you trying to say?
Yeah, I mean, you have the stuff.
You can keep guessing.
Oh, do you want to spend?
Do you want to buy a vowel?
Well, I only have this model because I had to.
I couldn't be a person today.
You're the one that was like, I really want to be a crow.
I gotta be a crow.
One of us delayed the stream so that they could be a crow.
It was fifteen minutes!
You had to get T anyway.
Okay, I wish...
I wish...
Like...
I know what the first word is.
I'm pretty sure.
You could spin and guess the ladder.
Take the risk.
I spin.
She spins.
Wouldn't it be funny if it was bankrupt?
It would be funny if it was bankrupt.
Wouldn't it be so funny?
Or lose a turn!
Lose a turn!
Alright, Matara.
Hold on, we gotta spin.
Guys, I have no idea what it is.
We spin for you?
I'm so bad.
May I please buy an eye?
An eye!
Wait, did you spin and then buy?
Yes, she did do that.
Are you sure?
Well, I guess I already deducted the money, so...
A single!
Can I please buy a U?
Oh, okay.
I thought it was fairy.
And not this word.
Like M-E-R-R-Y.
That's why I was telling Lime that of course she knows what the first word is.
Who says that?
I'm so dumb.
Can I please buy an A?
Oh my god, Matara!
What?
Let me spin my bunny!
It's all I got!
Okay.
Furry far.
No.
Furry...
jar.
It's a place.
Furry jar.
It could have been fairy.
Furry...
jar.
Furry bar.
Furry jar.
Or furry yar.
What is a yar?
Please, I want to go!
I know what this word is!
Would you like to spin Matara?
I mean, actually I don't even know.
Do you want to just guess a letter or something?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
It's either bar, car, or jar.
Can it be a par?
Okay, yeah.
It's either bar, car, or jar.
The logic!
I've never heard of it!
I don't know!
Why are you laughing at me?
Bar, car, or jar?
Oh yeah, I can guess why.
Why?
Okay.
Because that's not a vowel.
Good guess, good guess.
Furry bar in...
It's not...
frog.
It's not!
Please!
I know what it is!
It's a dog!
I don't know how to put these letters!
Zer...
Er...
Huh?
There's no vowels left.
You can guess anything.
I don't understand how there's no vowels left.
Do you want to spin?
Spin the wheel.
Oh my god!
That was close!
V!
God dammit!
Oh my god, guys!
Is it car or bar?
Oh my god!
Spin the wheel!
Okay, do it!
50-50!
No, no, no.
It's gonna get a C.
A C?
Because then I know that it's chat.
And then it's gonna tell me if it's bar or car.
We spin again, right?
Yeah, we spin.
We spin.
It's not bankruptcy.
I'm gonna cry.
Oh my god!
You're so close!
Alright, what do you want?
A C?
One C!
Furry bar in JVR!
I was not getting it, you guys.
There is nothing.
I do not play VR.
I do not read that.
These faces on the internet.
I was not getting it.
I'm so sorry.
I apologize.
It took literally until...
Furry car in VR chat.
It was not clicking for me at all.
It took until one letter was away.
I was like, is it bar or car?
We're just min-maxing the farming.
Yeah!
Look how much money you got.
What a strat.
I'm still third.
One second.
Check the DMs.
Check the DMs?
Yeah.
Sure.
Oh, sorry.
I don't know why it keeps doing that to you.
You keep becoming tickled.
You keep getting censored.
What were they doing behind that censor bar?
We'll never know.
We went to a furry bar in VR chat.
Sorry, I mean a furry car.
A furry jar in VR chat.
In Prague.
Furry bar in Prague.
Where did you get the frog from?
Is a furry jar like a swear jar where whenever you have furry tendencies you have to put money into it?
Oh, that must happen a lot in VR chat.
Probably, right?
I legitimately was not understanding what the word can be.
I was like, why is there no word?
I was in so much pain.
I was like, please.
Cool.
Let's go on to our next round.
Now Matara's on the board.
Oh my god.
She went third place.
How did she actually win this?
From third place to third place.
Matara gone.
What the fuck is this word?
This one is a phrase.
Sorry.
Since Matara.
Since Matara won.
We'll start with Croaky.
Here, we'll spin the wheel for you.
Use your brain cells.
Oh, L.
Is there an L on the board?
A single L.
I knew it would work.
I knew it.
Spin that wheel.
She did it, finally.
You know what I'm going to do, Matara?
I know what I'm going to do.
No, don't do that.
I'm going to take it.
I pick M.
M.
Is there an M on the board?
The one time.
There's an M?
You get it.
The one time you could have gotten M, I took it from you.
I'm sweating right now, you guys.
I'm sweating.
Alright.
Do you want to spin or buy a vowel?
Buy a vowel.
Spin that wheel.
Hey, I'm gonna get bankrupt from here.
I feel it.
Oh, that's close.
Manifesting.
Okay, this is a little more difficult.
Chat is too smart.
Buy a vowel!
Buy a vowel.
I can't buy a vowel!
Yes you can!
You have money!
I don't know what that word is.
Can I do T?
T!
Three!
I know what it is!
Oh my god!
Wait!
That is a Metal Gear reference.
Tink, tink, tink, tink, tink, tink!
Tink, tink, tink, tink, tink!
No!
The forbidden crow knowledge.
Cause that's metal!
And then I didn't know what the other sentences were until...
I mean, as soon as the word metal was fucking clear, we all knew what it was.
As soon as the word metal was clear, I was like that's metal, but then when I got T and then there was two Ts at the top I was like, oh...
That is a Metal Gear reference.
Nobody else even got to play!
You did it!
I could have spun more if I was like, no, this is guaranteed to win.
Oh my god.
Thank you for not drawing out my agony.
I was like, oh no, I'm gonna have to watch your farm every fucking day.
I thought you were gonna farm!
Seriously.
Who would do that, right?
Farm every letter?
Nobody would do that.
That's cringe.
I knew what the pain was, so I didn't do that.
You're out here like, hmm, could it be Metal Fear?
Could it be Metal Tear?
I don't know.
Metal Bear?
Metal Jar?
Frog?
Oh, please!
My biggest fear is for people to find out how dumb I am.
No!
No, Madara!
It's okay, I forgot O was a vowel!
Alrighty.
We have one final commercial break before we go to our final round.
Yoki in the lead.
And let's go to our last commercial break.
Don't leave everybody!
Don't leave!
We'll be back after these messages.
Don't skipa!
No skippa!
Here we go.
We're six doors.
We're just one.
So many commercials!
What else is on?
See all of this?
This is your future.
Welcome to your future.
S-C-S-A-M A-M Super College and Melons.
Good evening everyone.
And welcome back to Who Wants to be a Millionaire?
We are here with our contestant Frogbert.
And they are on their final question of the night.
The question that will determine if they become a millionaire.
How are you feeling tonight, Frogbert?
Narrator?
I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling like a million bucks are about to go in my pocket.
Oh yes, we can tell he is ready.
I'm just going to cut you off right there, buddy.
Because I don't want to waste any more time.
I know our audience is so excited.
I know you're so excited.
I'm getting heart palpitations.
So, let us let us do our final question of the night.
Are you ready?
Okay.
Here is your final question, Frogbert.
The final question is...
What is Mint's announcement?
And your options are... A.
A baby.
B.
What she's going to have for dinner tonight.
C.
Another announcement.
Or...
D.
A collab with Pitbull.
Mr. Worldwide.
Hmm...
A.
B.
C.
Or D.
I'm thinking A.
Because it does not say what kind of a baby.
What if it's a food baby?
Is that your final answer?
Yes, that is my final answer.
Okay.
Final answer.
A.
A baby.
We will find out if you'll become a millionaire after this commercial break!
Don't you step away, folks!
We're going to come back shortly and see if Frogbert wins this one million dollars!
See you in a few minutes!
I think I'm right.
I don't think so.
Hey you!
Are you currently watching this magic box?
Do you like ghosts?
Do you like maids?
Do you like ghost maids?
Do you like Mint Phantom?
What about Mint Phantom the same but slightly different?
That's right, folks!
Introducing Mint Phantom 3.0!
A whole new model!
We have a lore video!
We have a stream!
We have a reveal!
We have other surprises for you to gander at!
That's right, Mint Phantom 3.0!
Brand new model!
And when will this be revealed, you ask?
Well, it will be revealed this All Hallows' Eve!
That's right, Halloween night!
October 31st!
Uh, you heard it here first.
Folks, October 31st is Mint Phantom 3.0!
New model, new rigging, whole new look, except not really.
Come and join in on the fun today!
And see you then!
October 31st, 7pm EST!
Ah!
Oh, there we go.
Hey!
Oh!
Uh, uh...
Uh...
Uh, hold on.
Ah!
Uh...
Oh...
Yay!
Mint 3.0 debut!
Um...
Man, that sure had a lot of commercials!
Hahaha!
I hope you guys didn't get sick of all those commercials!
A baby!
It could...
It could have been a food baby.
Didn't say what kind of baby.
Yay!
Da-dun!
Da -dun!
Um...
Yeah, I'll have the waiting room up for that.
Uh...
After this stream!
Hahaha!
And, um...
Yeah!
Oh gosh, I'm nervous all of a sudden.
Because I planned everything.
And I didn't plan up to here.
Hahaha!
I planned everything else!
Until up until this point!
Hahaha!
Whoa!
Skip commercial!
No!
Did Frogbert win?
I don't know!
Put it back on Wheel of Fortune!
Thank you to, um...
Matara and Doki and Lime for joining me for my silly, um...
My silly...
Uh...
Wheel of Fortune game.
I hope you guys liked it too.
And, um...
Yeah!
Surprise!
It's kind of the same.
But not really!
Hahaha!
And, um...
Basically I was like...
Um...
How do I say?
Sorry, I'm really nervous all of a sudden.
Oh gosh.
Um...
Sorry!
Oh gosh!
I'm really nervous!
Hahaha!
I kind of...
I call it 3.0 debut.
But it's really, to me, like a re-debut.
When I first debuted...
Ever, ever...
I never had like a lore video or...
Never really kind of did a proper debut, I guess.
So, uh...
Did Doki win?
You'll have to see!
You can get early access to 3.0 if you pre-order.
Hahaha!
Yeah, pre-order.
Something.
Download more RAM.
Pre-order the RAM and you'll get access.
Hahaha!
Um...
Yeah, thank you for all the birthday wishes!
And, um...
And, uh...
I have lots of stuff planned for 3.0.
Um...
And it's on Halloween.
So I'm very excited about that.
It was actually initially gonna be for today.
Hahaha!
But, um...
To make it easier on everybody...
I pushed it to the 31st.
Because otherwise everybody would be scrambling.
And, um...
And, uh...
Um...
But yeah, I kind of...
Wanted it to be like a new...
Um...
A new start in a way.
If you're kind of like...
Wow...
I wonder when Minto's getting a new...
Or getting a 3D...
Well, this has kind of been part of what's...
Been holding me up.
Hahaha!
So...
Um...
To a new beginning!
Yeah!
But I didn't want to change too much.
So as you can tell...
From the little hidden bits...
I mean the...
The showing bits...
Hahaha!
It's pretty much the same.
But there are...
Some differences.
And if you guys are good...
I might give you a little sneak peek.
Later.
At the end of the stream, maybe.
A little bit of a sneak peek.
Maybe.
It's also not done.
Hahaha!
It's also...
Not done.
So...
Yeah...
But um...
Yeah, please be good.
Peek.
A snake peek?
No.
Oh gosh!
I'm glad that the...
Wheel of Fortune stuff worked out.
And that I could switch to...
Did you guys like my commercials?
Hahaha!
Thank you for all the super chats!
I really, really appreciate it!
Thank you!
I'm gonna bring the Minto 3D concert tickets.
Will Mitten 3.0...
Fix the hates chat bug?
Hahaha!
It's weird calling it 3.0.
Because...
It's kinda... I don't know if you can tell...
My first two models were...
Were...
KGR Mama.
But maybe...
This is a different Mama.
So it feels weird, you know?
Hahaha!
To say 3.0.
It's kind of like saying...
Saying...
Re-debut.
And I also...
I...
What was I gonna say?
Um...
Happy birthday Minto!
Thank you!
Ah...
I can't remember.
My mind is so blank.
Sorry, I also have really bad jet lag.
Hahaha!
Um...
But there are some things that are different.
Oh!
I feel weird about, like, making a big deal out of...
Debuting a model that...
You kind of already know what it looks like.
Because, like I said, it looks the same.
But not really.
But...
Um...
Uh...
There will be new rigging.
And...
Um...
New stuff.
So...
Um...
I hope you guys like it.
I really like it so far.
I can't...
I'm so excited to use it.
I thank you guys.
If you haven't already fallen in love with me...
You'll fall in love with me...
After you see me next!
Hahaha!
You'll be like, wow, wait a second.
I think Min's kind of cute.
Hahaha!
Do you know the mama?
Yeah, I know the mama.
Hahaha!
What do you mean?
Oh my gosh, what if I, like, ask someone random?
Can you ask someone to make me a model?
Hahaha!
And make my new body.
And...
Um...
Don't tell me.
It'll be a surprise.
Hahaha!
It's the mama gotcha.
Yeah.
So maybe actually Frogbert was right.
It's a baby!
And it's me!
I'm the baby!
Hahaha!
I'm
the baby!
Hahaha!
Yeah, maybe he did win.
I said on Twitter...
Whoever wins...
Whatever option wins will be...
Or whatever gets first will win.
But that also just means...
Whatever places first...
Wins!
Hahaha!
Never said it would come true!
I just said it would win!
That's it!
I'm the baby!
Hahaha!
New model baby.
Actually...
I'm not gonna lie.
My new look is very baby.
Hahaha!
My cheeks are really round!
I think it might be my favorite part.
Probably.
Maybe.
Nah, I have a lot of favorite parts.
I can't wait to show you guys.
Um...
Me and my mama, we really cooked.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
I've been...
Really looking forward to this.
It took a bit of waiting.
Um...
My mama was busy with...
Deadlines.
Hahaha!
And then...
Will new Minto be able to CQC?
Maybe!
Actually, probably!
Congratulations on the baby!
Thank you!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
So...
Aw, man!
Um...
I'm so excited.
Uh...
And then I will have more things on the 3.0 date.
So...
October 31st!
I'm so excited for Halloween!
Hahaha!
I hope you guys are excited.
Oh gosh, like I said, it's kind of awkward because it really is...
The same outfit.
It's not like a new outfit or anything.
I'm really sorry about that.
But, you know, I'm like making merch and everything.
And before anybody even gets my merch...
I didn't want to have a new whole look.
So...
But!
Um...
New outfits will happen from now on with new mama.
So...
Um...
My old model...
You probably won't see it anymore.
The one that... Not this one!
Hahaha!
But...
My normal...
Self that I use.
So 2.0.
But I think once you see the new one...
I think you'll be like...
Okay.
I understand.
Hahaha!
I think you'll understand.
I think.
And who knows?
Who's to say that I won't remake 1.0 in the future?
But with...
New mama.
You know?
I almost said the name.
Hahaha!
Yeah, so...
Hmm...
Taking bets she will have a nose?
I'm pretty sure she has a nose.
Pretty sure.
Ah!
But I'll keep... I'll keep...
Um...
Besides the little...
Preview I show you guys today.
If you're good.
If you're... If you're dandy.
Um...
Uh...
Then...
I'll keep it mostly secret until the day of.
So sorry you have to wait like a whole month.
Hahaha!
But I also have to wait a whole month so...
I'm probably more impatient than you guys.
I'm more impatient than you!
Um...
But yeah...
So... Did you guys like my commercials?
Here, let's uh...
Let's bring them up since I...
Made them.
Hahaha!
So first commercial we had was...
The mall.
The mall commercial.
And...
Hold on.
One second.
Oop.
Hold on.
Why isn't it not letting me?
There we go.
Hahaha!
Did you guys like this one?
Oh, hold on.
Let me... Let me make it so I can hear it.
I'll tell you...
My thought process.
Um... Which was...
Um...
Trying to make this as accurate as possible.
I was even gonna like remake the backgrounds and everything.
But I ran out of time.
Also, that's me.
Doing the...
Can you tell?
That's me.
That probably was the hardest part about this whole thing.
Doing the...
The beatbox.
And trying to make it...
As off sync as the original.
So the original was...
Hold on.
Was...
Uh...
What did she say here?
Wait...
Uh...
What did she say there?
Oh!
Denim!
Hahaha!
Instead I said...
And this one was...
But instead it's...
Hahaha!
Sorry, I'm laughing at my own jokes.
And then this one's...
Backpacks!
And this one is...
Boots and pants.
But I just thought...
Boots and cats?
That's how you actually beatbox!
With boots and cats and boots and cats.
And so...
Boots and cats.
Instead of boots and pants.
This one is the one I'm most impressed with.
I did this in one take.
And it's so...
Actually, I did all of these without watching the video.
So I would watch it...
And then go and record...
And mimic the actions without watching.
Like I would just...
I sat in a room and just went...
Without any audio or anything...
I was just like...
I would go...
And then I would do...
And I did...
I think like two times or something.
And so this one...
The fact that I got it so perfectly synced...
Kind of makes me...
Go bonkers.
Like even when I go back!
How did I time that so perfectly?
Maybe a genius.
That one is my favorite.
Because the girl is just like...
Get yourself an outfit!
It's my most accurate one.
And then this one I had to...
So...
They even have like a cut in the background.
And so I simulated that as well.
And you can hear me being like...
Get yourself...
And then I was like...
That's that commercial.
And then of course the one for the happy coat.
I filmed that.
I filmed this.
It's a little wide.
Because I filmed it on my phone.
And I had to squish it to fit.
So it looks more like that.
Actually.
It looks more like that.
In the video.
Because you had to make sure you could see it.
Um...
To...
To know.
And then I drew the butt.
But I didn't realize it would bleed through.
So actually also.
This had no script or anything.
Can you tell?
Can you tell it had no script?
That I just made this all up by myself.
In my brain at the moment.
It's not divine.
Actually.
Actually the only one with a script.
Was the mall one.
And then it kept turning sideways.
I was getting annoyed.
And that's real.
That's not CGI.
That actually happened.
The fire is real.
No weighing right now.
I'm also kind of obsessed with these frogs.
I don't know if you can tell.
But I really like them.
Leo get the happy coat.
Please.
Go to yeahlights.
Wait.
Where is it?
Yeahlights.com.
Pre-order my happy coat.
Please.
It even comes with this little nifty.
Like waist coat tie.
It's very cute.
It matches.
Everything is cute.
It's very.
Soft and nice.
It's so high quality.
As you can tell from the video.
Today.
Yeah.
My first ever official merch.
Oh don't look at that part.
So that was the happy coat.
Commercial.
And then the last commercial.
Which was a several commercials.
But this one.
You could stop at five or six stores.
Or just one.
You could.
Oh wait.
You could stop at five or six stores.
I forgot to do like you know how they go.
The five or six stores or just one.
And then they do the little thing.
And then they say like.
I'm a disappointment to my parents.
I forgot to say the last bit.
And then also this one.
The scam.
Sorry no SCAM college.
Sorry wait.
The college of melons.
This.
This is your.
So.
I did this.
Both in two takes.
One take.
The one.
And then the other take.
And then I forgot what I said the second time.
Which is why.
It didn't sync.
It didn't sync cause I.
Welcome to your future.
SCAM.
So at the very beginning.
I say like this is your future.
And then the other one says welcome to your future.
SCAM.
This is your future.
Welcome to your future.
SCAM.
Super college.
And melons.
But I was really impressed that I got the.
The super college part.
Or wait was it the SCAM part.
Oh where did it go.
SCAM.
Super college.
Yeah I got the super college in sync.
So that's kind of awesome.
Yeah.
First try baby.
First try.
But um.
And then the last one.
How can a ghost have a birthday.
It's my death day.
But I say birthday to make it easy for you guys.
Okay.
What's the announcement.
Me.
I'm the announcement.
And um.
And then.
The last thing I did.
Was the millionaire.
Which this.
Um again.
Each one was one take.
I think I'm.
I kind of scare myself.
With how well I think I know myself.
Because.
Essentially.
I had to say.
I did the mint take first.
Right.
And then.
I did the frogbert take.
And I had to remember.
How long of a pause and stuff that I did.
For each one.
And.
I just kind of whiffed.
For a minute.
Good evening everyone.
And I also had no script here.
We are here.
With our contestant frogbert.
And they are on their final.
Question of the night.
The questions that will determine.
If they become.
It was really silly.
Because I'm just.
Because especially for.
For this.
Hold on.
Actually do I have like the video.
Um.
Wait.
Oh.
Here we go.
Where's my recordings.
I don't know if you can hear that.
Like it would look like this.
And I'm just awkwardly.
By myself.
Sitting in the chair.
So.
Um.
Yeah.
And uh.
That was fun.
One second.
And.
Yeah.
Um.
I did that in one take.
I basically like I recorded the one part.
And then I was like.
I kind of had them.
I had to do frogberts.
Like mimicking whatever I said here.
But there was one part I forgot.
It was um.
I forgot what I said.
As frogbert.
Or rather as mint.
Me.
Sorry.
It's weird differentiating.
I know our audience is so excited.
I know you're so excited.
And I'm getting heart palpitations.
So.
Let us.
Let us do our final.
Question of the night.
Are you ready?
I forgot that I asked.
And so.
This part.
The frogbert's response was.
I forgot to record a response.
Is that.
Oh there's double audio?
Wait.
Wait what do you mean double audio?
You can hear it twice?
Oh.
Here?
Okay.
Now it's fine right?
Only for the videos you're playing.
Oh so.
Oh I'm so sorry you guys.
I thought that you guys couldn't.
Okay I thought it was okay.
Okay there we go.
But yeah so that was actually supposed to be.
Frogbert's intro.
That's why he's waving.
Here is your.
Okay.
So that's.
That's why it's kind of weird.
His intro.
Hold on.
I have frogbert's whole take right here.
It's just.
Oh wait hold on.
I can't hear it.
Give me a second.
It'll just be kind of like.
I don't think I cut out anything.
Hi.
So it was a lot of just.
Sitting.
And being quiet.
And just pretending I'm.
Responding.
And stuff.
Oh narrator.
I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling like.
A million bucks.
Are about to go in my pocket.
I'm feeling.
And I had to pretend.
That I was getting interrupted.
And everything.
And it all just kind of.
The timing all just worked out.
I think I'm a genius.
In my pocket.
So I had a lot of fun.
Making those.
They were a good time.
There we go.
The BGM is back.
So yeah.
I was trying to think of like.
What other things I could do.
Initially.
I was.
My first idea.
For the stream.
Was going to be.
Was going to be family feud.
With more people.
But it was kind of hard.
It was kind of hard.
Getting a bunch of people.
And I knew I was only going to have it.
For like an hour or so.
So it wasn't going to be super long.
But it was like gathering all the people.
And at the end.
Everyone was going to leave.
And it was going to be a showdown.
Between me and Frogbert.
But instead I did Wheel of Fortune.
Not Wheel of Fortune.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
And I made my own Wheel of Fortune.
Did you guys like my.
Actually we didn't even finish.
The other ones.
I had two other.
Oh three others.
I had three other categories.
One of them was another stream quote.
And that was.
Let's kill the hoe.
A classic.
And then.
The other one.
The one after was a song title.
That was rules of nature.
I had to sneak in another metal gear.
And then the last one.
I wasn't sure if I was going to be able to do this one or not.
It depended on how long each one would take.
You know.
The last one was a person.
And it was Tam Tender.
Which is kind of my brain rot.
Right now.
It's Tam Tam der.
Tam Dan der.
Tam Tender.
Hahahahaha.
So those are the other three.
That we didn't get to.
But I told Batara and Doki and Lime.
That it would be.
Just an hour.
So I didn't want to go too far over.
And yeah.
Oh yeah.
I was going to have a different advertisement for my happy coat, but I also didn't get to do it.
It'd be hard to describe.
That's my name you're laughing about.
Oh gosh.
I've watched it like 50 times.
It's so funny.
Damn, Jen!
But yeah, so... That was everything I planned.
All leading up to my announcement.
Oh, I forgot!
I forgot the last commercial, of course.
Can you guys tell I do my own editing?
Hold on.
You guys... I don't know how I found this music.
It is the most...
I heard this music and I was like, oh no, I think I found the one.
It's the most PP music I've ever heard of in my entire life.
It's so good.
Hold on.
There we go.
This also, I didn't have a script and I just...
I just did it all in one take.
And I'm...
I'm like...
And when I was editing it, I was like, I don't have time.
I gotta go today!
And so I just did it in one take.
And I was just...
And at the end, I'm just like, join us today!
And I was like, wait, it's not today!
I'm so dumb!
Do you like ghosts?
Do you like maids?
Do you like ghost maids?
Do you like mint phantom?
Yeah, I crossed out the Danny phantom or the Danny part.
This one...
Actually, there's like one thing about my new model that is cut out in this.
You can see it here.
But it's cut out in this version.
I don't know, maybe if you're...
If you can see, you can see maybe.
Yeah, you guys see!
The Ahoge!
Yeah, it's the same but a little different.
It's bringing back the Ahoge because I had Ahoge in my first ever spiritual form.
So I brought back the Ahoge, baby.
Yeah.
Sharp eyes can find it.
That's right, folks.
Introducing mint phantom 3.0.
A whole new...
Model.
We have a lore video.
We have a stream.
Why did I say that?
I couldn't...
I was like...
Oh, what will I have?
Okay, so I was like...
In my mind, I was like...
What will I have for my re-debut?
I'll have a lore video and I'll have...
I couldn't...
I couldn't think of anything else.
This is...
I literally...
I was like...
Oh, God.
Nobody's gonna get excited for this because it's so awful.
I can't even advertise my own stuff.
And again, I feel weird like making it such a big deal because it is not like a new outfit or anything.
It's just...
It's just me...
Shinier, maybe.
We have other surprises for you to gander at.
That's right.
Mint Phantom 3.0.
Brand new model.
And when will this be revealed, you ask?
Well, it will be revealed this fall.
Hallow's Eve.
That's right.
Halloween night.
October...
That was me forgetting what day Halloween is.
That was me...
Forgetting what...
31st.
What day is Halloween?
You heard it here first, folks.
October 31st is Mint Phantom 3.0.
New model.
New rigging.
Whole new look.
Except not really.
Come and join in on the fun today.
And see you then.
October 31st, 7pm EST.
Actually, I'm just gonna change this music to be today's background music instead.
Where is it?
Uh...
Oh...
Where did I save it to?
Uhh.
Oh, here it is.
It's so off!
But I will have other stuff at my debut.
Please come.
Like everything will be really new and shiny.
I'll have lots of new music and new other stuff too.
Hopefully, as long as it's done in time.
Nothing is finished.
Please, please come.
Why are there birds in this song?
I heard this and I was like, this has got to be the one.
Hold on, I want this guy on my screen too.
Look at him go!
I don't even know who these guys are.
I just found them.
Yesterday.
Okay, you guys are good sports.
I will give you a preview.
It's a short stream today.
I'm dealing with the jet hag.
I'm on the final boss.
Wait, where is my old music actually?
Oh no!
Wait!
I lost it.
Wait a second.
No, I didn't.
Was it this one?
Yeah.
Okay.
You guys want a preview?
I got permission for this preview.
So I can show you guys if you want a little sneak peek.
Don't worry, it won't be...
It won't be...
It won't be anything to give you away.
If you like surprises.
So...
In fact, watch this.
I'm gonna...
Actually, I don't know how cursed it will look.
As Chibi Minto.
But let's see.
Do you guys have to see?
Like this.
Okay, give me a second because I'm gonna go set up.
I gotta set up some stuff.
It's...
Um...
Give me a second.
Blurry, blurry.
I really appreciate it.
I'm sorry if we couldn't celebrate on the day of.
I hope you guys are still excited.
Nonetheless, I'm very excited.
Thank you guys for all the...
Oh!
I wanted to also go over some stuff from Twitter.
I've been looking at things.
On Twitter.
So...
Um...
We can do that.
I'll go through it just a little bit.
Some stuff too.
Hold on, real quick.
Okay.
It's gonna look really cursed.
Okay?
It's gonna look really ghastly even.
You might say.
Looks pretty cursed.
Probably.
Wow!
It's actually cute though.
I promise.
It will be much cuter.
The day of.
So...
So here it comes!
Yeah!
Come to my re-debut!
October 31st.
Yeah I know the more I zoom in, the more clear it becomes.
It's not finished though.
So, you can even maybe see some parts here that aren't finished.
Okie-dokie.
I go back to Chibi-B too.
All seeing!
I am all seeing!
Okie-dokie.
One second.
Thank you!
Thank
you!
Thank you!
For Super Chats, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Twitter!
Twitter.com There are some crazy things on here that I saw.
I was like, woah!
You guys were kind of...
I also stole the hashtag.
Sorry I didn't have one beforehand.
I'm a little silly.
Wait, where's the hashtag?
Where's my... there.
Ok.
I'm going to share some things.
Real quick.
One second.
Just a few things.
Like I said, today's stream isn't going to be very long.
I'm quite tired.
But also, I just wanted to have like a fun time.
And just have like a short fun time with you guys.
Not make it a super big deal or anything.
You know?
I do appreciate everybody being here though.
It's not my first birthday.
But it won't be my last.
We can celebrate next year too.
3.0 model defogger.
Okie dokie.
First thing...
Oh my gosh.
I saw this.
I have to go through and comment on everything.
So, I was looking at stuff I haven't commented or liked or anything yet.
Because I was like, oh gosh.
I got to go through everything.
But...
Ah!
Oh sorry.
Oh my gosh.
The transition scared the heck out of me.
Oh my god.
First...
TaoTan!
TaoTan is so cute.
Thank you for watching.
I never thought I would see...
I never thought I would see TaoTan cosplay me.
I was so excited.
I was like...
So cute.
Thank you.
So, so, so cute.
So cute.
I was...
I was like...
I was seriously fangirling this morning.
3.0.
Yeah.
That's my 3.0.
3D.
No.
I wish my 3D looked this cute.
She's so cute.
I was so excited.
I was like...
Oh!
I was just so excited.
So yeah.
Thank you TaoTan.
So cute.
Oh wait.
How am I supposed to...
Oh.
Um.
Ah.
Wait.
Oh.
I...
Didn't consider...
Hold on.
Ah.
Oh.
I have to adjust.
It's all done.
I'm stupid.
I'm sorry.
I...
Did this all wrong.
Okay.
There we go.
Another thing.
Ta-da!
Made!
Oh!
I'm not the maid.
I'm Ojousama.
No.
I'm always maid.
Thank you for the beautiful art!
Why is that wisp in the front so dapper?
And snake.
Everybody's here.
So cute.
Even snake gets a crown.
Are you just kidding?
It's so cute.
Thank you.
There's so much crazy stuff in here.
Like...
Oh!
Wait.
I just saw this.
Why?
I didn't get to see it.
Sorry, Huening.
I'm using your video.
Oh, there's so much art!
There's so much art!
Thank you!
Oh, Kami!
Oh, it all looks so amazing!
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Wow!
Yuki.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, thanks Ashes for putting this together.
I'm going to cry.
Let's see.
There is some more stuff.
Oh, this!
I wanted to watch this!
I didn't watch it yet.
Hold on.
I think it's fine.
Oh, let me scroll down a little.
This, this, this, this, this, this, this, this, this, this.
I want to watch.
Ah!
So nostalgic.
Done.
Happy birthday, Minto.
It's Jeffrey.
Jeffrey!
You'll use digital and they're residential taboo.
For those of you who don't know, I worked on Outer Wilds.
But if you actually noticed my work, that means I screwed up or you're a murderer.
Like me.
It was really fun joining your chat and watching your Echo stream.
Thank you so much again for playing our game and I'm glad you enjoyed it.
I hope you have another wonderful year on this new fresh journey of yours.
And speaking of smelling plants, don't forget to smell the pine trees along the way.
I have to go back to the Coding Mine, so I'll leave you here.
Until next time, Minto.
El.
Sai.
Kongroo.
Oh my god, I thought that's just what he wore normally.
Sick.
That was like sick coat.
Oh my
god.
Yeah, that's just how he dresses normally.
El.
Sai.
Kongroo.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Thank you, Jeffrey.
Thank you.
Thanks, Nano.
Oh my gosh, I'm Mintina now.
That's so awesome.
Oh my gosh, I'm crying from laughing.
These are so great.
This is so awesome too.
Hold on.
Oh, it's a little cut off.
That should be good.
Wait, a little more down.
Sorry, I might have to cut off a little bit.
Oh no.
No.
Does this have audio?
Oh, it does.
Ah!
Mom!
I'm in Pumark!
Here,
let's show the artist's name.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you can see.
Ah!
Hold on, I can uncrop it a little bit.
My blue archive.
It's so...
Oh my gosh, the different expressions and everything.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Oh my goodness.
I look so shy.
The art's so good.
Thank you!
You have so many jammies.
I'm gonna watch the beginning.
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
I should move the frog.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I forgot he was there.
Mint and blue archive win.
One day, I hope.
I'll do my best.
Thank you, thank you!
It's so pretty.
Wow!
Let's see what else we got here.
There's some other really crazy stuff in here.
I was like, wow.
You guys are so awesome.
There's all the art and everything.
I wish I could feature everybody.
Oh, there's another Times Square video.
Oh, there's another time.
Oh, there's a video.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
Birthday cake for me!
I have 19!
Yeah!
Asha, thank you!
Did you make that?
It looks so delicious.
I think I'll be spending all my pro...
I don't know how to say the prox...
...word, so I just got jammies.
It looks so yummy.
I haven't got...
Actually, after this stream, I was gonna go get cake.
So...
It's so good.
I am so happy.
I'm so happy.
Yeah.
It looks so good.
It's so drippy.
Just like me!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
It looks good.
Jeffrey!
I mean, I could wear that normally.
Thank you so much for the video!
It was awesome.
I'm so happy.
And this!
Wait, will it show?
The whole thing?
Rururu!
At my birthday billboard in Akihabara!
You look so awesome!
Thank you!
Here, I'll show the name.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
So cute!
Yeah, I actually got to see it.
It was so surreal.
Seeing me on...
On the radio kaikan billboard.
And seeing me...
On the Onoden billboard.
I was so...
Yeah, this radio kaikan.
This is where Steins Gate even takes place!
Like, oh my god!
Wow.
I...
I was so...
I was so moved.
Thank you!
So
happy!
I think I'm just really happy that...
That...
We could spend...
Another birthday together.
You know?
What is this Jerma video?
I'm scared.
I don't know this guy.
I'm scared to watch...
I'll watch that off stream.
There's something...
Oh, this!
Oh my gosh.
I...
This is so...
Tom!
You are so crazy!
This is so...
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Wait, I have to move it up a little bit.
AHHHHHH!
AHHHH!
It is!
Seriously my arms are even like that!
I'm doing....
It's so awesome!
And Ham thank you for all your character...
modeling and everything!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna put this on my computer right after this.
I'm gonna have the Minto virus... Minto virus real!
Wait, watch it again, watch it again.
And even...
Sorry, the dono is in the way.
It's the theme of Tara.
The theme of Matara.
It's so awesome.
Well, before Matara even debuted, I messaged her and I was like...
Yo, theme of Matara.
I was like, you have to use this song in your debut.
I don't think she ever did.
I was like, theme of Matara.
Oh yeah, yeah, here, here, here.
You can see...
The model.
Thank you, have!
It looks so awesome!
Wait!
Can this go into that mod, I wonder?
Can this go into that mod?
For putting...
Putting Minto in Metal Gear Solid.
I wonder.
Tom, thank you so much!
It's so awesome!
I saw this too!
This is so cute.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna let it redo...
I think now.
There we go.
Oh!
A snake?
Can it go inside the love box?
And I possess the love...
It's so cute!
Thank you for commissioning this.
It's so, so cute.
I saw this earlier too.
That is a Metal Gear reference.
Yes.
Every time I get Metal Gear art, I just lose my mind.
It's so awesome.
There's so much beautiful art.
So cute!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Wow, friend!
You're so cute!
Thank you for going to see the billboard in Akiba!
Oh my gosh!
I know it's kind of difficult.
You know, not every...
If you're not visiting Japan, or if you don't live in Japan, you know...
You know, my stream times are hard for Japanese viewers anyway, so...
My team was out of this world.
Big Ham posted the full model render in the tag.
Yeah!
I saw it!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
You guys went...
Everything is so crazy!
And then this!
Cool!
Oh my gosh!
I made a free resin 3D printable model for making Wisp keychains!
So if you guys want a Wisp keychain, you can 3D print your own!
And Cole made a little printable.
It's so cute!
I can't!
Everything...
Everything is so awesome!
Thank you guys!
Oh, I want to squish them!
I don't think you can squish the 3D printables.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I want to show off everything.
I don't really have time.
There's a Kudo board!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Oh, look at that!
Thank you, Fawn!
I will look at the Kudo board.
The Kudo board.
Takisoyo!
Oh!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I will look at this after stream.
Yeah, yeah.
There's just so much beautiful art.
Thank you guys for adopting the hashtag.
I will go through, of course, the...
My regular tag for things that weren't...
Because, of course, I didn't put the hashtag.
I put out a hashtag.
And so...
If you didn't use it, don't worry.
I'll still see your stuff.
I will still...
I will still retweet and everything, of course.
So...
Yeah.
I'm so happy.
Thank you guys for an amazing death day.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is so funny.
How did you...
Not the miss worldwide...
Mr. Worldwide collab.
Thank you, for the...
Thank you, Johnny!
Thank you!
How did you...
How did you make this so quick?
Oh man...
I really appreciate all the birthday gifts.
I saw some people sing me happy birthday.
And everything.
Yeah, Mint Chord sang me two birthday songs.
And stuff.
Actually, can I listen to this here?
Actually, will you guys be too embarrassed?
I haven't listened to it yet.
Will you guys be too embarrassed?
Let's listen.
Happy birthday to you.
Look at them singing.
Happy birthday dear Minto.
That's me!
Happy birthday to you.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
I don't have Phantom Pay with my birthday so...
This is the next best thing I suppose we could get.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Thank you for the hug, Super!
Thank you so much!
Oh!
Wait, I saw this too!
Oh my gosh, wait.
I wanted to watch it.
It's on YouTube though, hold on.
I didn't watch it with sound.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have to...
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, sorry.
I have to re-size and everything.
Here we go.
This looked crazy.
I was like, what is this?
What?
You guys are so crazy!
You guys are just so crazy.
There's just so much going on on my birthday.
I'm so shocked.
Wait, is this working?
Or am I stretching it?
I can't tell.
Wait, I'm confused.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, good, good, good.
Sorry, I'm trying to adjust the video.
Okay, here we go.
It's on AI Pod!
Maybe this is the best one to end on, huh?
Oh, it's the whole song, maybe?
Oh no, it's me!
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Is there something weird?
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Bustin' makes me feel good.
Thank you guys for such a great birthday!
Oh my gosh, this is so...
Ow!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Can't wait to hear the big announcement.
Wait.
Is that all singing and things?
Bop bop, sleeping in your bed.
Bop bop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm a miserable man.
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bustin',
bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Feel go...
Oh my gosh, the frog!
Yeah!
Get it, break it down!
Frog!
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man.
Freaky man, baby.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
Look at his toes.
Why is he standing like that?
In a miserable bed.
I don't think I like it anymore.
He's looking at Bustin'.
Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin'
Busted.
Look at him go.
Yeah.
Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Busted.
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
I think this is gonna demonetize this but that's okay.
Bustin' Bustin' Busted Busted.
That's okay though.
I hope you guys liked my birthday stream!
I hope you had fun!
I hope you, um, uh, eat some good cake!
Oh, it's over.
Oh.
I forgot that's how it ended.
Oh, wow, wow.
And, um, yeah!
Thank you guys!
I had a lot of fun, and I will see you guys, um, another time!
Oh, tomorrow, probably.
I don't know what my schedule is this week.
I'm streaming tomorrow, though.
I will be, I will be.
And, um... yeah!
Thanks for a great birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you...
I can only just say thank you.
I just feel so grateful right now.
Thank you, guys.
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
See you when I see you!
Okie-dokie!
See you next time!
Bye-bye!